رحب رئيس الحكومه الوحده الوطنيه الليبيه
عبد الحميد الدبيبه بجهود المبعوث الاممي
لوضع خارطه طريق للانتخابات واشاد في
تغريده له باستجابه الامم المتحده لطلب
رفع مستوى التنسيق والدعم المقدم في مسار
التحضير والاستعداد للانتخبات كما ناشد
الليبيين التحلي بالاراده القويه لانهاء
المراحل الانتقاليه عبر انتخابات عادله
ونزيهه
من جهه قال رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله
خالد المشري في تغريده ان هناك اراده
سياسيه قويه لاجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه قبل نهايه العام وبقوانين
انتخابيه تراعي القوانين المنظمه للعمل
السياسي والجنسيه وتنظيم القوات المسلحه
وتعهدات ملتقى جنيف اضافه الى مشاركه
الاحزاب والشباب والمراه في هذه
الانتخابات التي ستجمع كل مكونات المجتمع
الليبي حسب تعبيره